l'ordre du jour appelle le vote solennel
sur la proposition loi visant à
renforcer l'accompagnement des élus
locaux dans la mise en œuvre de la lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols
donc nous en venons aux explications de
votre et la première prise de parole
c'est Monsieur Stéphane delaît pour le
groupe socialiste et apparenté
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs chers
collègues comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire en discussion générale mon groupe
regrette l'absence d'une grande loi de
programmation sur le foncier adaptant
nos objectifs de politique publique au
nouveau cadre de 0 artificielisation
nette et prévoyant son sein ou dans une
loi de finances un cadre financier et
fiscal qui en soit l'outil opérationnel
bien sûr une proposition de loi
ordinaire ne se prête que peu à la
définition d'un tel cadre pour autant un
amendement de rapport de nos collègues
écologistes sur la dimension fiscale a
été adoptée nous nous en réjouissons
tout comme du large soutien de principe
qui a été apporté à notre amendement
proposant une loi de programmation
foncière aussi dans la continuité de ces
échanges nous proposerons au président
de commission concernées la création
d'une mission d'information commune afin
d'initier un travail parlementaire
transpartisans sur ce sujet notre groupe
était très réservé sur le contenu de la
proposition de loi sénatoriale certes
des mesures sur les délais par exemple
avaient pour effet de priver
d'effectivité les dispositions prévues
pour la période 2021 2031 quand d'autres
sur la comptabilisation et la définition
des projets nationaux notamment
permettait de fait un dépassement
significatif de l'objectif de réduction
de 50% du rythme d'artificialisation des
sols par rapport à la période décennale
précédente le texte ça cependant connu
une évolution favorable tout au long des
débats dans notre assemblée en premier
lieu les reports excessifs de délais
prévus par le Sénat ont été supprimés
avec pour seul exception un report
limité à 6 mois pour l'estradettes afin
de tenir compte des décrets
d'applications et des effets de la
proposition de loi en second lieu le
principe de comptabilisation des projets
d'intérêt national européen a été
introduit même s'il s'agit d'une
comptabilisation à part dans un forfait
national de 15000 hectares nous
entendons la nécessité de laisser de la
flexibilité mais regrettons que nous
amendements encadrant les éventuels
dépassements de ce plafond n'est pas été
retenu certes la définition de ces
projets a été largement précisé même si
elle laisse encore des marges de
manœuvre confortable à l'état un
équilibre semble néanmoins trouvé dans
cette nouvelle rédaction à condition
qu'il demeure en CMP enfin le mécanisme
de poupée russe déclinant l’implique
l'implication entre progénationaux
régionaux et locaux a été précisé nous
comptons fortement sur le dispositif de
clauses de revoyure pour bénéficier
d'une évaluation et d'un suivi précis
des consommations d'espace notamment
suite à l'adoption de nos amendements
donnant une dimension qualitative à ces
évaluations en troisième lieu le
mécanisme de la garantie rurale a été
sanctuarisé mais il est désormais
conditionné résistance d'un document
d'urbanisme prescrit arrêté ou approuvé
avant le 22 août 2026 cette condition de
meurt cependant souple si nous avions
proposé une définition alternative un
équilibre est là aussi trouvé avec notre
amendement garde-fou qui préside qui
précise que la garantie rurale ne fait
pas obstacle à l'application des règles
de construction limité
prescrite par le RNU dans les communes
concernées nous saluons également
l'intégration d'une possibilité de
mutualisation à l'échelle locale après
avis de la conférence des maires même si
nous aurions préféré une logique
intercommunale à cet égard le texte
résultant des débats en séance et donc
sensiblement améliorer et comporte dans
ces dispositions principales un certain
nombre d'équilibre entre préservation du
zen
problématique rurale et flexibilité de
mise en oeuvre éclosent de revoyure en
2026 pour ces raisons monsieur le
ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mon
groupe votera pour le texte résultant
des travaux de notre assemblée ce
soutien ne doit se vendre cependant pas
être compris comme un blanc simple
monsieur le ministre vous nous avez
demandé en anticipant la CMP de ne pas
dépasser les lignes rouges des sénateurs
notamment sur la logique de l'hectare
dans le cadre de la garantie rurale nous
comptons donc sur vous pour porter de la
même manière auprès des célibataires les
points d'équilibre important adoptés
dans notre assemblée et qui constitue le
fondement de notre vote sur la
comptabilisation et la définition des
projets nationaux sur l'encadrement des
communes relevant du RNU ou encore sur
les délais d'actualisation des documents
d'urbanisme à défaut notre position de
vote sur le texte qui sortira des
travaux de la CMP pourra évoluer nous
avons certes besoin d'adaptation pour
garantir l'application d'usage pas d'une
CMP conclusive conclusive à n'importe
quel prix je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Luc lamiro pour le
groupe horizon et apparenté
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
économiques mes chers collègues
nous avons tous bien conscience que la
consommation de terres agricoles et
naturelle à un impact sur notre
réchauffement climatique ainsi la lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols et
bien identifier tant au niveau national
qu'au niveau européen comme un enjeu
prioritaire pour la préservation de
l'environnement et de la biodiversité
il nous faut donc être volontariste pour
diminuer les risques qui pèsent sur
notre sur notre planète il faut aussi
tenir compte du fait que nous ne pouvons
pas changer de mode de vie du jour au
lendemain des efforts ont déjà été
réalisés et soulignent la prise de
conscience de beaucoup d'entre nous
nous donnons plus de chances de succès
pour nous donner plus de chances de
succès pardon il nous faudra poursuivre
l'accompagnement de la conversion des
friches industrielles et de la
restauration des bâtiments anciens nous
devons renforcer notre incitation
financière
pour consommer pour moins consommer il
nous faut réutiliser
après plusieurs jours de débats en
commission et en hémicycle nous avons pu
compléter et préciser cette proposition
de loi issue du travail de nos collègues
sénateurs elle répond aux inquiétudes et
incompréhension des élus locaux elle
incite et favorise le dialogue entre
collectivités et principalement avec la
région
les projets économiques d'envergure
national seront pris en compte sans
réduire nos ambitions environnementales
les régions pourront les accompagner en
réservant des espaces pour les besoins
de logement qui en découlent
la garantie rurale offre à chaque
commune une surface minimum d'un hectare
cette disposition constitue la
possibilité pour les communes de prendre
en main leur développement à cela
s'ajoute la mutualisation souhaitable de
ces hectares au sein des communautés de
communes afin de permettre la
réalisation de projets de plus grandes
de plus grandes ampleur cela favorisera
le dialogue intercommunal
certaines régions se sont données de
contraintes supérieures à la loi c'est
le cas de la région Centre Val de Loire
qui a fait le choix dans son schéma
régional d'une réduction de 50% d'ici
2025 au lieu de 2031 dans la loi et un
objectif de 0 artificialisation nette
d'ici 2040 contre 2050 dans la loi
au sein de la Conférence régionale du
zan ces régions devront être pédagogues
et expliquer leur choix plus
contraignant j'espère que les régions
seront écoutées les élus dans cet
instant où les mers seront désormais
mieux représentés
la renaturation des espaces la
reconquête des friches industrielles et
la restauration du bâti ancien
nécessitera une mobilisation financière
importante au groupe horizon et
apparentés nous serons donc très
attentifs aux résultats du rapport sur
l'articulation l'articulation de la
fiscalité et de l'objectif de sobriété
de consommation d'espace nous espérons
qu'il pourra nourrir nos réflexions lors
du budget
le groupe horizon apparenté soutient les
adaptations prévues par la présente
proposition de loi permettant de réduire
la consommation d'espaces agricoles et
naturels et de préserver ainsi notre
capacité à lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame Marie pochon pour le
groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs chers
collègues
mercredi dernier le gouvernement
présentait le décret portant des
solutions des soulèvements de la terre
derrière les faux prétextes et les
opérations de com pour faire plaisir à
certains lobbys le véritable motif de
cette décision est passé sous silence le
gouvernement souhaitait aux
productivisme mais à la croissance
refuse l'impératif de protection de nos
terres si les lâche de criminaliser un
médecin qui bloque une route pour
dénoncer un projet qui va aggraver la
pollution de l'air une agricultrice qui
refuse l'accaparement de l'eau par
quelques industriels ou un scientifique
qui sait plus comment vous faire
entendre les conclusions de ces travaux
c'est surtout totalement
inefficace
croire que cela va calmer la colère que
celui-ci de votre politique destructrice
est inapte s'imaginer que cela change
quoi que ce soit à la réalité physique
et biologique de l'effondrement de notre
monde est un conséquent plus les seuls
seront détruits plus les crises du
climat et de la biodiversité
s'aggraveront plus notre souveraineté
alimentaire sera menacée plus les
risques naturels seront amplifiés
il n'est pas facile d'être décideur
aujourd'hui nous avons chacun dans nos
circonscriptions des élus locaux qui
nous pressent pour que nous facilitions
des permis de construire pour que les
habitants de chez nous et les moyens de
se loger dignement et des objectifs de
zéro artificialisation à tenir
vous-même vous acharnez à préserver d'un
côté l'impérius nécessité de la
croissance et celui souvent bien moins
cité de préserver l'habitabilité de la
terre on nous sommes de bâtir de
construire de faire toujours plus quand
la planète entière nous commande au
contraire de ralentir
ralentir 25 000 hectares sont encore
artificialisés chaque année et nous
sommes meurent il n'abrutent plus la
riche biodiversité d'antan ne stocke
plus autant de carbone et ne retiennent
plus l'eau
face à cela notre Assemblée a décidé en
2021 de fixer le cap du 0
artificialisation nette en 2050 et une
étape intermédiaire de division par deux
de l'artificialisation d'ici 2031 c'est
une première étape indispensable et elle
n'est pas facile pour s'en rendre compte
il suffisait d'écouter la droite et
l'extrême droite durant nos débats la
semaine dernière aucune considération
pour la science et la défense d'un
modèle d'aménagement des années 70
reposant sur la destruction de nos
terres agricoles de nos forêts de nos
zones humides un naturo scepticisme
affligeant
face à cela monsieur le ministre nous
pouvons reconnaître que vous avez tenu
et défendu les objectifs de la loi
climat
le texte qui sort de cette assemblée est
sensiblement meilleur que celui proposé
par le Sénat néanmoins certains points
restent problématiques et justifieront
notre abstention sur ce texte des points
de détails comme la version actuelle du
décret nomenclature ou la rédaction
l'article 10 sur les zones ayant
vocation à être renaturé la garantie
rurale dans sa forme actuelle reste
également un mécanisme sous optimal et
insatisfaisant allouer un hectare par
commune fait fide leur spécificité et
pour une communauté de communes comme le
dit wa dans la Drôme ce seront 50
hectares qu'il n'avait même pas songé à
artificialiser
mais surtout nous avons je crois un
point fondamental de discorde vous
n'avez pas encore fait le deuil du
productivisme du siècle passé
contrairement aux collègues de la droite
de l'Assemblée vous ne niez pas les
réaliser scientifiques et vous
reconnaissez les bénéfices de la
transition mais vous êtes incapable de
la concrétiser et de la mettre en
pratique or quoi que vous en pensiez
protéger nos terres suppose d'abandonner
les projets du passé on ne peut pas en
même temps imposer des restrictions
importantes à nos communes et en même
temps laisser faire les extensions
d'aéroports les projets autoroutiers les
plateformes logistiques XXL les fermes
d'usines les LGV et j'en passe et c'est
pourtant ce que vous faites avec la
défense de vos projets d'intérêt
nationaux derrière lesquels se cachent
bien souvent les grands projets inutiles
et imposés
vous semblez n'avoir rien appris de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes du barrage de
Civens de la Montagne d'Or d'Europa City
chaque fois vous vous êtes entêté devant
l'évidence chaque fois vous nous avez
fait perdre du temps vous avez gaspillé
l'argent public pour vos nouveaux
projets comme pour les précédents la
suite de l'histoire est toute tracée les
scientifiques vont alerter les paysans
vont protester les citoyens vont se
mobiliser et la Terre va à nouveau se
soulever
et lui écologiste et ici je voudrais
saluer ma collègue Isabelle ouko qui
attend un euro-événement et ne peut pas
être présente aujourd'hui malgré son
attachement à ce texte nous sommes
convaincus que les solutions résident
dans l'écoute des scientifiques et des
citoyens et dans la protection et le
partage équitable est durable de nos
terres nous appelons la majorité à avoir
le courage de cesser tous les grands
projets d'aménagement inutile et
destructeurs sans attendre de perdre des
écosystèmes précieux et des milliards
d'euros d'argent public nous l'appelons
à investir cet argent dans nos villages
à soutenir les projets de revitalisation
des campagnes
la remise en service des petites lignes
ferroviaires l'installation massive des
paysans la rénovation thermique du bâti
des centres bourg les initiatives de
solidarité la protection de nos forêts
de la biodiversité et de l'ensemble des
aménités rurales
c'est nul ne peut gouverner contre le
peuple nul ne peut gouverner contre la
nature les voies de nos soulèvements ne
cesseront donc que lorsque vous
renoncerez à éventrer la terre je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole et maintenant
à Monsieur Sébastien jumelles pour le
groupe gauche-démocrates et républicaine
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur président de
commission monsieur rapporteur monsieur
rapporteur collègue réduire
réussir à réduire l'artificialisation
des sols est un principe est un enjeu
majeur pour la transition écologique
personne ici n'en doute pour
l'agriculture comme pour la biodiversité
le défi est là et nous devons y répondre
sans jamais oublier que la meilleure des
réponses et la démocratie locale le
travail accomplit tout au long de
l'examen de ce texte répond je crois
mieux à ce préalable il a permis de
revenir en partie sur la méthode aveugle
qui avait introduit de la loi climat et
résidence sans prendre en compte les
bilans de chaque territoire en matière
d'artificialisation ni garantir une
équité de traitement le zinc s'est
appliqué jusque là comme un outil à
fracturer des territoires comme une
usine à emmerdement et je dis dans
l'intervention générale en effet dans
l'état actuel la règle s'exerce
uniformément à tous indépendamment des
efforts et du passif de chaque
territoire
un reflet de la France que certains sur
ces bancs soutiennent volontiers avec en
résumé d'un côté des métropoles les
territoires qui vont bien dont le quota
d'artificialisation est en réalité
atteint depuis longtemps et qui gagnent
même un peu de temps avant de devoir
fournir des efforts tout à fait
négligeables avant l'entrée de lasagne
et de l'autre des territoires plus
souvent oubliés de la métropolisation
qui s'ouvre déjà du recul des services
publics de l'éloignement urbain et dont
les efforts à réaliser sont-elles qu'ils
empêchent toutes possibilités de
développement nous le répétons ici une
telle règle décidé dans le confinement
des salons ministériels ne peut être une
bonne règle elle est au contraire une
raison supplémentaire du sentiment
d'humiliation qu'on ressenti certains
territoires nous pensons qu'à la faveur
de ce texte
nous franchissons un premier pas nous
pouvons construire une autre méthode
pour limiter l'artificialisation des
sols en tout cas pour l'encadrer d'abord
en réaffirmant que le droit au projet
n'est pas incompatible avec la
préservation du foncier car oui nous
avons besoin à l'avenir plus que jamais
travaillé à soutenir le maintien et la
protection du foncier agricole notamment
qui reste le grand absent quand même des
réflexions gouvernementales ensuite en
disant qu'il existe d'autres moyens pour
atteindre nos objectifs en particulier
on s'attaquant avec sérieux à la
question des friches d'activités et
locative pouvons-nous sérieusement
penser qu'avec seulement 750 millions
d'euros monsieur le ministre nous
pouvons s'en prendre à la question des
cent mille hectares de friche
industrielles de notre pays j'ai fait un
ratio assez facile 8300 friches 750
millions ça fait 27000 euros pour
travailler sur les friches c'est
évidemment le compte qui n'est pas nous
avons ici monsieur le ministre en angle
mort que le texte ne règle pas au même
titre que la question des vacances
également et qui conviendra de pousser
beaucoup plus loin lors de la discussion
budgétaire au risque sinon de faire du
zan encore une fois une limite plus
qu'une nouvelle étape dans le
développement des territoires les
limites étant connues nous saluons le
travail effectué par notre assemblée et
l'ouverture d'esprit du rapporteur et du
ministre sur ce texte en ce sens nous
accueillons positivement l'élaboration
de la garantie rurale qui va desserrer
un peu les taux réservé aux communes
rurales notamment celle en RNU même si
j'insiste sur le fait qu'il faudra les
accompagner pour avoir les moyens de
l'ingénierie et pour avoir les moyens de
passer du RNU du aux cartes communales
je veux saluer aussi le fait que les
textes est intégré la problématique des
grands chantiers d'envergure nationale
européenne pour faire en sorte que les
efforts ne pèsent pas sur des
territoires qui contribuent ainsi je
veux dire un aménagement du territoire
national nous accueillons également avec
intérêt la précision apportée par le
rapporteur sur la comptabilisation des
aménagements induits par ces grands
projets et je notais positivement
monsieur le ministre votre engagement à
venir à Die PPE voir comment tout cela
se concrétise avec le projet auquel nous
devons faire face enfin la réécriture
étoffée de la Commission de la
gouvernance du zan je crois que Yannick
était très attaché à ça Yannick Money
pour que les élus soient mieux associés
à la gouvernance
préalable à l'élaboration des stadettes
était évidemment une bonne chose cette
commission devra être respectée nous
craignons néanmoins qu'elle soit
contournée par certaines régions qui
aiment bien se comporter comme la
tutelle sur les autres collectivités
mais nous serons avec vous vigilants
pour que les élus locaux soient
respectés enfin je veux dire quand même
que sur l'outre-mer il nous faudra
progresser encore un peu plus pour
prendre en compte la spécificité
exprimer légitimement par nos collègues
ultramarins sur les problématiques liées
je pense notamment aux collègues de
Guyane mais tous les ultramarins ont
manifesté la nécessité d'avoir une
reconnaissance de la spécificité de leur
situation regarde des questions de
fonciers disponibles rapportés aux
besoins de correction des injustices
territoriales dont les ultramarins sont
victimes toutes ces questions monsieur
le ministre en pragmatisme conduiront le
groupe GDR sa composante communiste et
sa composante ultramarine à émettre un
avis favorable à cette proposition de
loi un vote favorable vigil ant exigeant
mais un vote favorable tout de même
[Applaudissements]
pour le groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoires
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le président de commission
tout le monde s'accorde à vouloir
protéger les terres agricoles et les
milieux naturels si le but est louable
la méthode doit être équitable
nous devons effectivement repenser notre
manière de construire éviter l'étalement
massif et la dévitalisation de
centre-ville préserver notre
souveraineté alimentaire qui passe par
la préservation des terres agricoles
mais nous devons également préserver la
vitalité et le développement des
campagnes
le dispositif 0 artificialisation nette
a été construit à la va-vite créant
beaucoup de difficultés et ouvrant peu
de possibilités les élus locaux se sont
retrouvés confrontés à une formule
mathématique sans prise avec la réalité
des dynamiques économiques et
démographiques de leur territoire très
vite des frictions entre l'objectif
louable et la lutte contre la déserte
l'artificialisation des sols ce sont ces
jours à ce propos nous regrettons que
les dents creuses de nos territoires
ruraux ne puissent être magnésiés ce
serait un bon moyen d'économiser la
terre agricole
ce dispositif qu'on nous avait proposé
était mal ficelé avec une vue urbaine et
centralisatrice une définition
contestable des données manquantes une
différenciation et une territorisation
insuffisante un flou entourant la
comptabilisation des grands projets les
conditions étaient réunies pour gripper
la situation
les mers sont particulièrement
mécontents
comment mener des projets
il risque effectivement de se retrouver
coincé tout simplement pour développer
leur commune avec un risque d'explosion
en raison de l'arrêtfaction des terres
créant des situations de rampes pour les
propriétaires et paupérisant en
particulier les jeunes qui sont parmi
ceux qui s'ouvrant n'ont pas de maison
et non pas de bien foncier
il est temps de remettre les choses je
dirais sur le bon rail la proposition de
loi sénatoriale que nous avons examiné
va dans le bon sens en répondant à
certaines questions laisser la tente par
le la loi climat résilience la première
est celle de la prise en compte des
projets de grande ampleur national ou
européenne sont-ils toujours légitimes
on en a discuté tout à l'heure mais
certains territoires vont accueillir un
nombre important d'infrastructures en
l'état du Zéro artificiel nette cela les
empêcherait de mener par ailleurs
d'autres projets d'aménagement
concrètement le zan actuel leur demande
de choisir entre une ligne à grande
vitesse ou bâtir des crèches des
logements ou des terrains de sport vous
avez tenté d'y répondre
avec un forfait national comprenant
l'ensemble des projets de grande ampleur
qui sera soustrains de l'enveloppe
nationale elle-même répartie entre les
régions deux inconnues demeurent quelle
sera la formule assurant à une
pondération entre les régions les
régions qui n'accueillent pas les
projets structurants accepteront elles
d'en partager la charge le débat n'est
pas clos
il aurait sans doute été plus simple de
sortir ses grands projets de l'enveloppe
comme le demande le Sénat et certains
membres du gouvernement autre sujet
important celui de l'aménagement de nos
communes rurales sur ce point le texte
met sur la table une proposition
intéressante la garantie rurale cette
hectare laissait au petites communes
leur permettra de dégager des marges de
manœuvre pour construire des
infrastructures ou des logements il
redonne une perspective à celle qui
redoutait de perdre toute capacité
d'adaptation le point positif également
l'aménagement du calendrier pour tenir
compte dans les documents d'urbanisme
des objectifs relatifs à
l'artificialisation des sols nous nous
réjouissons enfin que grâce à l'action
de notre groupe le dispositif face objet
d'une plus grande territorialisation
encore sans particuliers
l'artificialisation il sera mieux
encadré dans les communes et rainues
tout simplement par la sanctuarisation
du paduk
et on a vu avec l'exemple de
Porto-Vecchio que cela s'imposait
d'autres sujets sont en revanche laissés
en suspens au premier rang desquels se
financier la lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols va
profondément bouleverser la fiscalité
locale la dotation globale de
fonctionnement inversée aux
collectivités et corréler de manière
directe à la croissance au développement
d'une collectivité plus elle aide
infrastructures de voirie de services
plus elles dispose de DGF de la même
manière plus une commune dispose de bâti
plus elle perçoit de taxes foncières
quelle refonte de la fiscalité pour nous
mettre en place pour pallier aux pertes
attendues de ses ressources et c'est
particulièrement important autre effet
de bord du zan le renchérissement des
prix du foncier notamment pour les
jeunes je les dis comment dans ces
conditions garantir l'accession la
propriété de tous être propriétaire de
sa maison sera-t-il désormais l'apanage
des plus riches nous attendons
évidemment une grande loi sur le
logement
la maîtrise de l'artificialisation est
nécessaire mais cette question ne peut
se réduire à des calculs plus ou moins
élaborés nous voterons en grande
majorité cette proposition de loi
puisqu'elle contribue à rendre le
principe de 0 artificialisation nette
plus opérationnelle nous restons
persuadés cependant que d'autres
aménagements nous attendent dans le
futur je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Pascal Lavergne pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
aux affaires économiques messieurs les
messieurs les rapporteurs je voudrais
également associer à cette prise de
parole ma collègue Pascal Boyer qui
était également
coanimatrice en fait de ce de ce texte
pour pour la Commission d'aiderat le
vote aujourd'hui et l'aboutissement d'un
long travail collectif de concertation
et de dialogue un travail un travail de
plus d'un an tout début de mandat nous
avions effectivement évoqué ces
questions là un mot pour le ministre
évidemment les rapporteurs qui ont
beaucoup travaillé
accompli un travail formidable aux côtés
de leur collaborateurs que je
souhaiterais également saluer le texte
que nous apprêtons à voter est un texte
équilibré à mon sens les obstacles ont
été nombreux la tentation électoraliste
était là l'incohérence également de
certains qu'on a pu voir jusqu'au
dernier jour mais l'enjeu était trop
grand pour se donner le luxe de ne pas
partir sur un texte et l'enjeu sur le
foncier est majeur parce que le foncier
est extrêmement convoité aujourd'hui
pour de multiples usages ce texte vient
rappeler paroles fortes non on ne mesure
pas la performance d'une commune à sa
capacité à s'étendre la capacité à
préserver les paysages les espaces pour
se nourrir et protéger la biodiversité
et tout aussi noble j'espère que tous
les groupes se prononceront
favorablement sur ce texte qui a été
travaillé et construit avec tous les
acteurs et qui reprend des amendements
de tous les groupes j'en profite pour
saluer une députée qui a été leur
présentée par notre collègue Marie
pochon du groupe écolo qui je vous
laisse citer donc Isabelle Locko qui
était là jusqu'au dernier jour et qui
effectivement dans quelques dans
quelques jours sera sans doute maman et
qu'elle a défendu un amendement à la
dernière minute je crois que ça fait
partie des derniers abonnements que nous
avons
qui a été adopté à l'unité l'unanimité
je voudrais saluer donc Lisa et lui
souhaiter bon courage pour accueillir
son enfant
l'enjeu de consommer moins vite le
foncier de nos espaces est absolument
essentiel et ce texte est à mon avis
juste parce qu'il rend le zanne plus
acceptable pour tout le monde car s'il a
nécessité de consommer moins de fonciers
étaient communément admises partout la
mise en application sur le terrain
laissez apparaître des difficultés le
premier texte avait sans doute la main
un peu lourde celui-là a plus de doigtés
voilà pourquoi nous voterons avec
enthousiasme pour ce texte en attendant
une CMP conclusive avec le concours de
tous les députés
je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant à Madame
Christine en grand pour le groupe
rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs chers
collègues il y a maintenant deux ans
régnait ici un profond un profond
consensus sur les mesures à adopter pour
lancer la France dans la lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols à l'époque
nous n'étions malheureusement que 6 est
mis à part nous et notre présidente
aucune voix dissidante pas l'ombre d'une
contradiction aucun groupe n'avait eu le
courage de dénoncer ceux qui s'avèrent
être aujourd'hui l'une des mesures les
plus injustes de la politique
d'aménagement française
il aura fallu attendre une opportunité à
saisir l'imminence des élections
sénatoriales pour que nos collègues les
républicains bientôt rejoint dans la
panique par des députés Renaissance en
quête d'assistes territorial pour leur
partie se décide enfin à lever le petit
doigt pour nos communes rurales
votre précipitation on la retrouve
malheureusement partout dans ce texte et
élaboré dans l'urgence auquel rien
n'aura été épargné entre l'électoralisme
du centre et de la droite la démagogie
de la démagogie de la gauche et la
suppression de cet article en commission
avec votre accord collectif l'antenne a
identifier la subsistance d'une trame
logique dans ce gruyère et si c'est une
fois de plus la verticalité de ce texte
qui écarte encore les petites communes
des débats autour de la réduction de
l'artif de l'artificialisation des sols
au profit d'une tutelle régionale
technocratique des déclinaisons
territoriales de ces objectifs
de notre côté nous n'aurons eu de cesse
de dénoncer cette dilution du poids
communal dans les discussions
d'insister sur la nécessité de mettre en
place des mesures d'assouplissement
d'assouplissement réellement pérenne la
densification et le renouvellement
urbain sont une nécessité mais pour
produire des effets encore faut-il comme
nous l'avions proposé par amendement
redonner une place prépondérante à nos
mères au lieu de donner le pouvoir aux
petites communes nous repartons dans une
dilution d'un pouvoir donné au
métropoles et à la région bien trop loin
des Français
pour autant l'on ne serait s'opposé à un
texte qui réserve ça et là de 1 ou 2
articles dont les améliorations quoique
médiocre pour nous reste bonne à prendre
et c'est pourquoi nous voterons pour
cette proposition de loi merci
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur William Martinez
pour le groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues le sujet traité par cette
proposition de loi le zéro
artificialisation nette n'est pas un
sujet comme les autres trouver les voies
et moyens pour d'abord réduire et
ensuite stopper notre consommation de
terre naturelle agricoles et forestière
et pour l'humanité une question
existentielle la terre naturelle est un
trésor si vous en ramassez une poignée
vous aurez dans votre main plus de
micro-organismes qu'il n'y a d'êtres
humains sur le globe vous pourrez
observer de près une ressource
infiniment complexe que la planète a mis
des siècles à générer la terre est une
matière indispensable au cycle de l'eau
et du carbone sans elle il n'y a tout
simplement plus d'écosystèmes compatible
avec la vie humaine il a fallu du temps
pour que nous prenions conscience de ces
vérités pour comprendre que la terre
n'est pas seulement un objet que l'on
piétine pour comprendre que couler une
dalle de béton est un geste écocide aux
conséquences irréversibles mais
maintenant nous le savons les
scientifiques nous ont éclairé plus
personne dans cette hémicycle n'a
l'excuse de l'ignorance
l'artificialisation des sols est une
limite planétaire et on ne discute pas
on ne négocie pas on ne repousse pas une
limite planétaire il n'y a qu'une
alternative soit nous intégrons cette
limite dans notre modèle de
développement soit nous provoquons un
bouleversement de l'écosystème qui
conduira à notre perte chers collègues
bifurquer ou disparaître voilà la
question qui nous est posée
malheureusement ce n'est pas cette
proposition de loi qui apportera une
réponse sérieuse la faute a des
sénateurs LR qui ont légiféré au service
de leur campagne électorale incapable
d'assumer leur rôle d'opposition au
gouvernement ils ont trouvé plus
opportun plus facile de devenir les
premiers opposants aux ânes quel manque
de courage mais personne ici n'est dupe
député LR député à Ren dans cette
discussion vous n'avez pas défendu le
monde rural inquiet de la mise en œuvre
du zan vous avez défendu un modèle de
développement archaïque un modèle qui
vit dans l'illusion qu'un État le
meilleur bain infini est possible un
modèle qui se résume par le triptyque
autoroute parking supermarché un modèle
qui pourtant a fait tant de mal à la
ruralité nous la France insoumise avons
pris au sérieux cette question est
notamment les inquiétudes des mers
ruraux nous en avons tiré plusieurs
conclusions d'abord à propos de
l'article 7 nous considérons que cette
nouvelle version de la garantie rurale
qui permet de répartir plus
équitablement les efforts de réduction
de l'artificialisation des terres entre
métropoles et ruralité est une bonne
mesure elle est aussi un moyen de
préserver la souveraineté municipale à
laquelle nous sommes attachés mais
ensuite qu'est-ce que cette proposition
de loi apporte à la ruralité pour
l'aider à mettre en oeuvre le zan rien
comment lutter contre la vacance des
logements comment réhabiliter les
bâtiments vétustes et parfois sans
mettre comment construire le bourg sur
le bourg pour éviter l'étalement comment
apporter des moyens d'ingénierie au
maire des petites communes qui sont si
démunies pour mettre en oeuvre une
politique d'urbanisme il n'y a aucune
réponse à ces questions fondamentales
l'Association des Maires Ruraux de
France réclamaient un plan Marshall vous
les avez envoyé balader
à ce stade vous comprendrez que nous
sommes pour le mois sceptique et
l'article 4 de cette proposition de loi
réécrit par le rapporteur n'arrange pas
l'affaire cet article 4 est un point de
désaccord non seulement l'État n'est pas
aux côtés des communes pour la mise en
œuvre d'usane mais il s'octroît un droit
à artificialisé au nom de grands projets
d'intérêt national européens qui sont en
réalité les grands projets
inutiles imposés et écossible nous
sommes au cœur de la contradiction de la
macronie des tirads d'écologiques et en
même temps la possibilité de multiplier
les autoroutes les extensions
d'aéroports les lignes à grande vitesse
les centrales nucléaires et à la demande
express du ministre le maire les
gigafactories des lones musk ça vous
rend quelques projets qui rentreront
dans les critères de ce fameux article 4
le lion Turin 30 milliards pour percer
la montagne et artificialiser des
milliers d'hectares de terres naturels
tout ça alors qu'une ligne ferroviaire
existe déjà et qu'elle est en sous
capacité
le tronçon d'autoroute Toulouse Castres
500 hectares de zones humides sacrifiées
avec à la clé des supers profits pour
une société d'autoroute et des cancers
du poumon pour les gens la gare de la
ligne 18 du Grand Paris Express qui
s'installera en plein champ sur le
plateau de Saclay va artificialiser des
centaines d'hectares parmi les plus
fertiles d'Europe non jetons plus nous
avons suffisamment de preuves pour
démontrer que la macronie est encore et
toujours au service du Vieux Monde
productivisme du capitalisme dévoreur de
terre mais ce système ne durera pas
éternellement vous pouvez mettre toute
votre énergie pour réprimer et
criminaliser le mouvement écologique
vous n'empêcherez pas la résistance de
s'organiser nous sommes là nombreux pour
dénoncer votre hubrique pour rappeler
que les limites planétaires existent et
que personne ici n'a les moyens de la
faire disparaître collègue vous l'aurez
compris ce texte n'est pas à la hauteur
il n'apporte des solutions que très
partiel à la ruralité et il est surtout
un soutien au grand projet inutiles pour
ces raisons et à ce stade de la
discussion nous nous abstiendrons je
vous remercie
je vous remercie je fais donc annoncer
le scrutin dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale
et la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Vincent Roland pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la Commission d'affaires
économique messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le ministre en 2021 la loi
climat est résiliente à introduit des
termes qui sont encore peu connus de nos
concitoyens mais qui rêvaient une
importance forte zéro artificialisation
net si notre groupe partage le souci de
préserver notre environnement de
protéger la diversité de nos territoires
et de notre écosystème c'est dans les
moyens pour y recourir que nous émettons
des réserves
l'objectif zan relève d'une logique
sous-jacente que nous commençons à bien
connaître celle de la décroissance
une logique dont il est facile de
prévoir les conséquences la mort de
notre ruralité l'entrave aux initiatives
de développement le renforcement des
inégalités entre les zones rurales et
les polluents jusqu'à l'explosion des
coûts du logement la réalité c'est
pourtant que notre pays a besoin de
fonciers
si bien que nous sommes devenus le pays
le moins industrialisé de tous les
grands pays d'Europe des millions
d'emplois perdus des savoir-faire
disparus un tissu industriel affaibli
réparer ce qui a été brisé
nécessitera trois choses de la volonté
des moyens et surtout du foncier il sera
toujours préférable pour la France de
relocaliser les productions plutôt que
de faire traverser la planète à des
produits dans un super porte-conteneur
d'ailleurs nous pouvons que regretter
les contestations de ceux qui même quand
il s'agit d'entreprises accélérant la
transition écologique préfère s'opposer
parfois violemment à tout projet je le
répète nous partageons l'ambition de
surmonter le défi climatique mais nous
pensons aussi qu'elles ne pourra être
atteinte que par des politiques
publiques non pas par des politiques
publiques hors sol or comment qualifier
des politiques comme celle du zan ou des
et des feux qui vont purement et
simplement pénalisés les familles
modestes
l'écologie punitive et socialement at
soutenable
alors autant dire qu'après avoir fait ce
constat édifiant l'objectif zan tel que
voter en 2021 porterait un rude coup à
toutes les initiatives soutenues par nos
élus locaux il en serait même rural ici
surtout les territoires des montagnes de
ma chère Savoie au littoraux partout
dans notre ruralité l'inquiétude par
rapport à cette mesure monte appliquez
tel quel
s'est stoppé net le développement
économique de nos territoires au profit
des polluants
aggraver en mettant à mal la
construction d'habitat permanent l'une
des pires crises du logement de notre
histoire
la question est désormais de mieux
répartir l'effort donner de nouveaux
outils à nos petites communes pour
qu'elles soient pour qu'elle ne soit pas
pénalisée tout l'enjeu est de préserver
l'équilibre entre le développement rural
et urbain
proposé par nos collègues sénateurs à la
suite d'un travail transpartisan et
dessérant un peu les contraintes le
texte qui est devant nous a fait l'objet
de plusieurs modifications en commission
commencez je pense à la suppression de
plusieurs articles au bénéfice des
décrets dont nous surveillerons aussi la
rédaction il intervient comme une
mission une session de rattrapage notre
groupe ne peut que regretter les rejets
des propositions faites et qui visait
notamment à desserrer un peu plus le
calendrier de remise de documents
administratifs à intégrer le logement et
les infrastructures des décès qui est au
grand projet toutefois la garantie
rurale l'évolution de la composition de
la conférence régionale ou encore la non
prescribilité des stradettes vont dans
le bon sens c'est la raison pour
laquelle notre groupe soutiendra toutes
les mesures permettant d'atténuer le
poids que représente le zan un tient ne
vaut-il pas mieux que deux tu l'auras je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie
mes chers collègues est-ce que pour le
dernier orateur
est-ce que vous voulez bien juste
diminuer le volume des conversations
s'il vous plaît pour qu'on puisse
entendre notre dernière oratrice madame
Marina Ferrari pour le groupe démocrate
je vous remercie
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues au fil des décennies le
foncier sur certains territoires a
souvent été malmené consommé sans
compter et parfois urbanisé à outrance
cette période est résolument terminée et
nous savons bien que le foncier socle et
support de tous nos projets de
développement ou de protection constitue
un enjeu incontournable pour notre
avenir commun dans son analyse de la
consommation d'espace et de
l'artificialisation pour la période
2009-2019 le serema vous le savez
pointer ainsi que 277 000 hectares avait
été consommés en France sur la période
soit l'équivalent du département du
Rhône et qu'à ce rythme d'ici 2050 c'est
l'équivalent de la Corse qui aurait pu
être consommé si rien n'avait été fait
si le rythme de consommation des espaces
naturels agricoles et forestiers marque
le pas ces dernières années il est
désormais admis par tout ce que la
préservation de ces espaces est
indispensable pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et protéger
notre environnement l'artifice
l'artificialisation des sols à des
impacts sur la ressource en eau la
disparition de la biodiversité et le
stockage du carbone aussi la loi climat
irrésilience adoptée en 2021 poursuit un
but principal louable rationalisé et
limiter l'artificialisation de nos
espaces mais si les objectifs sont
partagés chers
dans son ensemble qui pose des
difficultés aux élus locaux plus d'un an
après l'adoption de la loi nous avons
tous été interpellés et à de nombreuses
reprises mes chers collègues par les
élus au sujet du zan et d'autant plus
par les élus de la réalité du littoral
et de la montagne qui m'est cher le
constat est unanime les consignes sont
trop contraignantes et pour certaines
rendent difficiles l'application d'usane
en fonction des spécificités
territoriales alors que la crise du
logement est devant nous comment ne pas
pénaliser les communes mes chers
collègues qui ont été les plus
vertueuses en termes de consommation
foncière ces dernières années comment
tout en préservant l'esprit et
l'objectif de la loi climat résilience
ne pas empêcher les communes de se
développer et de se redynamiser quels
sont les questions auxquelles cette
propositions de loi d'initiative
sénatoriales s'il vous plaît
c'est donc
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît
c'est donc avec pragmatisme et suite à
un travail collectif entre les élus
locaux et le Sénat le gouvernement est
suite à nos discussions dans cette
émission
que le texte équilibré est un texte de
compromis et qu'il sera aujourd'hui
soumis à notre vote je tiens ici à
saluer au nom des députés du groupe
démocrate le travail conduit et la
qualité des débats que nous avons menés
sous l'impulsion de nos deux rapporteurs
et du ministre et je m'étonne d'autant
plus de voir deux groupes les
écologistes et la mélenchonie s'abstenir
sur ce sujet
lorsqu'il s'agit de rendre de la
souplesse au territoire de les
accompagner dans leur transition
économique et écologique et dans une
optique de solidarité territoriale les
élus responsables et ambitieux savent se
retrouver en effet mes chers collègues
je crois que nous avons trouvé un
équilibre entre protection de la
biodiversité et attractivité de nos
territoires notamment face aux enjeux de
la réindustrialisation au service de la
décarbonation de notre économie le test
qui vous est proposé permet notamment
les aménagements suivants une enveloppe
de 15000 hectares sera dédiée au projet
d'envergure nationale ou européenne tel
que par exemple les opérations
intéressantes à la défense et la
sécurité nationale les projets
industriels d'intérêt national voyageurs
pour notre souveraineté et la transition
de développement de notre partie s'il
vous plaît est-ce qu'on peut baisser
d'un ton merci mais également les
opérations de construction des lignes
ferroviaires à grande vitesse et n'en
déplaise à certains le projet de la
nouvelle liaison ferroviaire entre Lyon
et Turin souhaité par 80 % des habitants
de la région verdrenal grand projet
écologique et européen sera ainsi
comptabiliser dans cette enveloppe ce
qui est un bon signal pour les
territoires supports de ce tracé cette
proposition de loi apporte par ailleurs
un cadre des bac que nous allons avoir
la semaine prochaine lors de l'examen du
PGL industrie verte deuxièmement enquêtu
ou ancien élus locaux et attaché à la
décentralisation il nous tenait à cœur
au sein du groupe démocrate de permettre
au territoire de constituer une
enveloppe différenciée pour les projets
d'intérêt régionaux majeur de même la
création d'une garantie d'un hectare
nous paraît essentiel pour ne pas
alimenter l'enclavement de nos communes
rurales laissons leur la possibilité de
créer une structure de service public du
logement ou une nouvelle zone d'activité
lorsqu'elles en ont l'opportunité enfin
concernant la méthode nos travaux mes
chers collègues n'ont pas vidé de sa
substance le texte issu du Sénat
parce que ce qui a été fait par voie
réglementaire doit également pouvoir
être modifié par voie réglementaires
certains articles du texte initial vous
le savez ont fait l'objet de décret déjà
porté à connaissance du public et qui
garantissent à la fois le respect des
objectifs de la loi climat et résilience
et l'esprit des évolutions que nous
avons voulu ensembles parce que notre
groupe a contribué à la création du
forfait national de 15000 hectares à la
mise en œuvre d'une enveloppe de projets
régionales et à la possibilité de
mutualiser la garantie rurale entre
commune les députés démocrates modem et
indépendants voteront sans réserve ce
texte je vous remercie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie chers collègues parce
que vous avez réussi à baisser d'un ton
pendant la dernière intervention et donc
je vais mettre au bois la proposition de
loi merci de regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin donc votant
535 exprimé 441 majorités 221 pour 437
contre 4 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
et si on peut renouveler l'attention
qu'il y a eu pendant la dernière
intervention nous vous serons tous
reconnaissants madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
11h en commission 15h en séance publique
une quarantaine d'amendements adopté de
tous les bords et ce texte qui recouvre
cet enjeu crucial de la lutte contre
l'artificialisation c'est-à-dire à la
fois
préserver le stockage du carbone
préserver la biodiversité préserver
notre souveraineté et nos espaces
agricoles et faire en sorte
que nous puissions avancer avec un
objectif mais en tenant compte des
besoins à la fois de la ruralité et des
grands projets
ce texte
il a encore des marges d'amélioration
qui ne pouvait pas se retrouver dans ce
débat là mais qui sont autant de
rendez-vous à venir et c'est là dessus
que j'aimerais conclure
d'abord en vous disant dans la
continuité des interventions qui ont eu
lieu qu'il manque les moyens pour le
mettre en oeuvre le soutien l'ingénierie
des communes en particulier rurales et
les trajectoires fiscales qui permettent
de faire en sorte qu'on ne pousse pas à
l'artificialisation alors que nous
souhaitons dans le même temps nous
concentrer sur les espaces qui le sont
déjà
il manque un plan friche qui soit à la
hauteur de la priorité que nous voulons
donner à la dépollution leur
identification
la priorisation de ces espaces et les
moyens budgétaires pour que les
collectivités locales puissent faire en
sorte de s'y concentrer et il manque
enfin et sans doute au-delà de ce texte
une vision à la fois de l'aménagement et
de l'après 2031 qui devrait être au cœur
des réflexions les plus transpartisanes
possibles parce que notre patrimoine
ça n'est pas seulement le fruit de ce
que nos anciens nous ont légué en ferme
de construction c'est aussi la somme de
nos paysages de nos espaces et de nos
sols qui sont autant de richesse dont
nous sommes les dépositaires temporaires
avant que d'autres prennent le relais je
voudrais en terminant remercier toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont fait vivre
ce débat remercier le président zoulesi
et le président kasbariant pour le
travail en commission remercier les
rapporteurs Lionel cosse et Bastien
Marchive remercier les principaux
orateurs de tous les groupes qui se sont
succédés à cette tribune en ayant une
pensée aux côtés de Marie pochon pour
Lisa bellucco pour les raisons qui ont
été indiquées et en saluant ce qui dans
l'ombre des orateurs principaux
ont permis que nous puissions progresser
il nous reste un rendez-vous c'est celui
de la rencontre avec la Haute Assemblée
pour que de deux textes on en est un qui
soit applicable et qui permettent de
faire en sorte de conjuguer ambition
pragmatisme et mise en œuvre merci à
tous
[Applaudissements]